[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
evolutionary psychologist he's an author
youtube and many other things GAD sod
they call you the Godfather welcome to
trigonometry oh so nice to be with you
guys I heard a lot about your show so
thank you for inviting me it's fantastic
to have you on but most of our fans will
know exactly who you are but for anyone
who doesn't just give us a little
insight into who are you how are you
where you are and what has been your
journey through life that lead you
inexorably here so I was born in Beirut
Lebanon grew up there till the age of
eleven we were part of a last group of
remaining Jews in Lebanon at one point
there was a larger community of Lebanese
Jews I mean still a very small community
but larger than when we were there and
through the 20th century they would be
sort of various exodus of Jews because
it would become more precarious to be
Jewish in our Arab lands but we hung in
there until 1975 when the Civil War
broke out it was a very very brutal
civil war all civil wars are judged
against the standards of the Lebanese
civil war and there were many many
militia that were fighting the problem
for Jews is that they didn't have too
many friends there were some amongst the
Christian militia that were warmer
towards the Jews but it became clear
that we had to find a way to regrettably
leave Lebanon so I so I spent the last
year of my life in Lebanon experiencing
the brutality of the civil war but
luckily we all escaped came to Canada
grew up in Montreal from the age of 11
did my undergrad in mathematics and
computer science at McGill University
also known as the Harvard of the north
and then did an MBA with a
specialization and operations research
at least the mini thesis and operations
research which is an applied mathematics
field then
went on to Cornell where I did a Masters
of Science and a PhD my PhD was in
psychology of decision-making really I
specifically looked at when is it that
we've acquired enough information to
make a choice so that this is called the
stopping decision so for example if I'm
choosing between two cars to purchase or
two political candidates to choose from
or two girls to marry when is it that I
have acquired enough information to say
okay I'm ready to stop acquiring
information I'm ready to buy car a I'm
ready to vote for candidate B so
contrary to classical economic theory
which argues that we should look at all
of the available information before we
make an optimal choice we don't do that
right we there might be a hundred
attributes that we can look at but we
only look at twelve before before we
stop and make a decision so I looked at
the cognitive processes that drive that
stopping decision then I obtained a
professorship at Concordia University
now in my PhD I had been bitten by the
evolutionary bug the evolutionary
psychology bug which at the time was a
nascent discipline I had read a book
that had been assigned my first semester
as a boxful student by a professor named
Dennis Regan where he assigned a book
called homicide written by two
evolutionary psychologists husband and
wife theme where they looked at patterns
of criminality from an evolutionary
perspective and I had my epiphany right
there that I would be doing exactly the
same thing but instead of applying
evolutionary psychology to study
criminal behavior I would spend I would
use it to study consumer behavior
and so then I went on and you know had
so far I'd like to think a successful
career as a as an academic as a
scientist at the intersection of as I
said evolutionary biology evolutionary
psychology and consumer psychology and
then I increasingly became more engaged
in the public sphere where at times I
would be weighing in on scientific
issues but more broadly I would weigh in
on all kinds of nonsense that is that
has infected the occur in the academic
world became problematic and as long as
what happened you'd be paid me for
making problematic
again I am so too to use your the start
of your podcaster trigger I'm basically
the granddaddy of triggering sound like
a rapper get well by the way
incidentally for those of you who don't
know how I got my name the godfather in
action there's a rap story I've done so
I've been approached by a rapper a
Canadian rapper who's you know become
reasonably long known for a particular
niche he basically raps about science he
raps about evolution precisely because
he wants to have a medium to attract
young kids to the science evolutionary
theory and so on and so he was
apparently a fan and he reached out to
me and said hey would you like to be in
my next rap video it's called I am a
African and so then I put out a call on
social media I said hey guys I'm gonna
have a separate career now as a rap star
if you give me some street cred names
that I can go by you know I don't want
to go by dr. sad professor Silas or I
need some street cred
so people proposed all sorts of names
none of them I mean there were so many
great ones but none of them stuck and
then one day I was sitting at my local
cafe talking to the to the owner of that
cafe telling him that story and he
stopped and he said oh that's easy
you're the Godfather thank you known as
The Godfather so contrary to some of the
idiots out there who think that it's a
manifestation of my grandiose narcissism
that I'm calling myself the Godfather
it's not me who came up with it it was
that gentleman question right and and so
we started with you being toxic and
problematic we want to get to your
research which is fascinating and you
know particularly the stuff you're
talking about how people reach that
decision threshold a lot of our fans
will know francis has yet to propose to
his girlfriend after 10 years so we'll
find out what's going on there from you
but before we do that you've got an
upcoming book which obviously we're
drawn to is called the parasitic mind
how infectious ideas are killing common
sense and the question I have for you is
with the corona virus and the lockdown
are you hopeful that your book will know
can be necessary it's more necessary
than ever because the corrode I've now
resorted to calling the idea pathogens
that I talk about in my book as the
coronavirus of the human mind right so
the the basic idea of would you like me
to summarize a bit don't know let's go
forever so let's let's start back with a
start from this from the beginning with
a quick story about neuro parasitology
so parapsychology is the study of
parasites
now parasites can infect an organism in
many places right there are some
parasites that go in your gut there now
neuropathology is parasites that go to
an organism to a hosts brain and there
are also some incredibly macabre and
fascinating examples of these neuro
parasites that can hijack the behavior
of an animal some you may have heard
about mentioned one or two so the
classic example that some of your
viewers would have heard of is
Toxoplasma gondii so this is a parasite
that will infect the brains of mice such
that they will lose their innate fear of
cats they will actually become sexually
attracted by the smell of the cat's
urine that's not a good thing if you're
a mouse right but it's a good thing for
the parasite there's another type of
parasite that parasitizes the brain of
ungulates deer moose elk and so they'll
start and gate once they are infected
they'll start engaging in circling
behavior their heads are kind of
listless and they go around in circle
unable to extricate themselves from this
motion even though the looming predators
might be coming at them they can't
extricate themselves from that behavior
so then I take these examples from the
animal kingdom as any good evolutionary
theorist should do because we can learn
a lot from our animal cousins and then I
argue that humans can of course be
paralyzed by actual brain parasites like
the ones I've just described but there's
a second class of parasites that they
can be
regrettably parasitized by and that is
bad ideas so I call these idea pathogens
and and they are just as devastating in
the same way that the deer that doesn't
run away for
the looming predator is going to end up
the bad consequence these idea pathogens
even a singular one can be devastating
but once you put them all together they
become truly devastating to our ability
to think to to to be reasonable to have
rationality to have common sense and so
then as any good epidemiologist would do
and that's why we the corona virus is so
apropos here you need to start looking
at where did this virus originated from
and unlike the castrati who tell us that
you know viruses have no origin no they
do have an origin it's called
epidemiology you try to find out where a
virus starts from so in the same way
that the this virus started in Wuhan
China I look at where do these idea
pathogens start from and regrettably I
say this as a professor they all start
from academia they start from the
University so the original place of
infection so in other words the the
plate is where they're really idiotic
ideas come from is from fellow
professors so the next question is what
are some of these ideas so
post-modernism is the granddaddy of idea
pathogens because it is perfectly anti
science
anti logic anti reason it's intellectual
terrorism there are no truths it's only
my truth that matters the scientific
method is not the only way to seek truth
it's only one of many ways it's white
science right so once you start with
this type of idea pathogen you literally
are putting dynamite and all of the
edifices of reason and all of the ways
by which we try to understand the
natural world so other examples of idea
pathogens social constructivism we're
all born with empty minds and it's only
our socialization that makes us who we
are bio phobia the rejection that
biology has an effect on human behavior
all true a relativism who are you to
judge whether cutting off the clitoris
ism of little girls is a bad idea don't
be a racist you bigot
identity politics right inclusion
inclusion diversity is what I call the
dye religion diversity inclusion and
equity has now infected all of the areas
of excellence
and including academia whereby we no
longer give lofty professorships to
people who are deserving but if I'm a
transgender woman of color who is into
indigenous studies then I'm much more
likely to receive it this is insane it's
nonsense and so this is what the book
does is it traces the disease and then
it offers some inoculation some vaccines
against is my ideas and and Gary you're
talking about post-modernism and I mean
by the way what you said all sounds
incredibly problematic we might have to
cut that from the interview but anyway
um but surely in the age of a
coronavirus where we're seeing tens of
thousands of people die isn't that the
perfect inoculation against some of this
nonsense because there is objective
reality it's people dying you know it's
amazing that you say this because that's
that would be the the naive intuitive
optimistic hypothesis which is with such
a you know dreadful reality that we're
all facing it kind of washes out all the
stupidity the reality though is that an
animal is most dangerous just before it
is about to die so as these ideas are
dying that's when a lot of these morons
are doubling down right so so now we
have an investigation of how the corona
virus affects women more even though men
die more right so in the same way that
Hillary Clinton said well the fact that
it is always men who overwhelmingly die
in war that the real victims are the
women that are left behind right so so
we're seeing the transgender activists
are linking coronavirus to
transgenderism the the the race peddlers
are linking it to race issues so yes I'd
like to believe that what you're saying
is true but I think the the animal is
wounded by Hannibal I mean the the
idiots who espouse these ideas and so I
think there'll be a doubling down before
we're eventually able to cull out these
ideas from from our public consciousness
yeah and why are you so concerned this
is a question that interests us
specifically because you know I'm from
Russia originally as I find one of
Francis mother's from Venezuela you
escaped from Lebanon a lot of the people
who
seem to be incapable of tolerating the
stuff and just shutting up about it seem
to be people who've come from a
background where you know the freedoms
and and the prosperity that we enjoy in
the West couldn't be taken for granted
do you think there is there's something
that the of having an experience outside
of the comfortable West that makes you
more reluctant to just you know you have
an accomplished career you could just be
doing your studies and not getting
involved in any of this do you think
that's part of why you feel so strongly
about it yeah no great question so here
I'll turn back to evolutionary theory
actually so any of us is a product an
inextricable mix of our genes and our
environment so contrary to what a lot of
folks say the tractors of evolutionary
psychology argue that the environment
evolution psychologists don't think that
the environment matters nothing could be
further from the truth
but so so you and I are a as I said an
inextricable melange of our genes and
environment so so to answer your
question I'll first address the genes
part then the environment by the
environment part meaning that you grew
up in Russia Venezuela and Lebanon the
genes part is that the unique
combination of genes that constitute the
personhood that is gas odd as such for
better or worse that I cannot tolerate
[ __ ] I am physically ill by
hypocrisy by intellectual dishonesty by
intellectual arrogance that masquerade
money that you this is called the
dunning-kruger effect right I pretend I
think that I know so much but in reality
I'm only overconfident in my stupidity
so all of these things are really
personally injurious to me so that when
I go to bed at night if I feel that I
haven't done all that I could and
whatever small or whatever big way that
I can to contribute to eradicate the
stupidity then I feel that I have failed
in my own personal conduct so that's the
individual element of why I do what I do
to answer your question but I exactly
agree with you that we are also a
product of our unique life trajectories
and so having grown up in Love Actually
chapter one of my forthcoming book is
exactly answering your question we
when you grow up in Lebanon where you
see what blind tribalism does what you
see what identity politics does but here
identity politics is that it when I
stopped you at a militia roadblock and
you are of the wrong religion we put a
bullet through your head right we don't
just eat mob you on Twitter right so
when you see what lack of freedom is
what blind zealotry is we're a departure
from R equal weather departure from
reason is then you come to the West and
for many years you feel as though you
you're now going to be in a steady state
of reason and then suddenly you have a
second war that starts the first war I
first was a Lebanon the second war is
the war against reason in our
universities then I say wait a second I
don't want to return to Lebanon now that
doesn't mean that tomorrow we will sink
to Lebanon but give it enough times 10
years 50 years 100 years 500 years if we
are not committed to all of the things
that made the West great that allowed us
to come to the West then we will be the
next Lebanon and so I completely agree
with you my life trajectory makes me
that much more committed to fight
against that nonsense and God you say
that we could end up like Lebanon why is
it why can't we just let people who have
bad ideas why do we have to consistently
challenge them after all this is a free
society some people are entitled to
believe what they think aren't right oh
you can I am I'm a true free speech
absolutist and that I believe that the
idea of shutting down people because
even objectively wrong idea so let's
take it the most extreme position that
supports my position I am Jewish having
escaped Lebanon as a Jew so few people
could have my Judaism as ingrained in my
identity as I am even though I'm by the
way an atheist but but culturally and so
on I'm very in my identity I'm very
Jewish yet I support the right of
Holocaust deniers to appear on campus
and say that the Holocaust that had
happened so there couldn't be any more
of a commitment to free speech
absolutism than that example right
there's nothing more grotesque there's
nothing more of an affront to truth than
to
say the Holocaust didn't happen or it
wasn't six million Jews it was six
thousand Jews right and yet I support
their right so it's not that I don't
support the right of people to have my
ideas on the contrary bring out your bad
ideas and let me smash you as the
apostle of truth I was not for poetry
so you genuinely basically what you
believe is bad ideas should be discussed
but I guess what you're pushing back
against and probably the reason you feel
so strongly about it we now live in a
society where if you are perceived to
have the wrong ideas by the
establishment then you must not speak
you know if you believe that there's
male and female you must not be because
that's transphobic or insulting to
minorities well exactly I mean listen I
appeared in some of yours may know this
or not but I appear in front the
Canadian Senate when Bill c16 in Canada
was being discussed PLC 16 is that the
bill that incorporates gender identity
and gender expression within the rubric
of hate crimes and of course my position
was not that transgender people should
not be free of bigotry right so that's
that's a nonsense
I mean of course I support that right
but what I was saying is that in this in
the service of trying to protect people
people from bigotry we don't murder the
truth right so the fact that in the 21st
century an evolutionary psychologist has
to appear infront of the Canadian Senate
and say no no really believe me there is
such a thing as male and female well no
there is this thing that Darwin talked
about called sexual selection which is
one of the main drivers of how traits
morphological features and behaviors
evolved and he based it on the fact that
bra there is bail and female that
shouldn't be something that I have to do
in front of the Kings Senate but the
reality is because of the position I
took there which is literally laughably
obvious right the average two-year-old
knows that that's true as a matter of
fact that's one of the first markers
that you use to identify yourself if not
others is your biological set the the
fact that I did that I already saw how
universities in general
in some cases my own University started
distancing themselves from me right so
it's great that I have this huge
platform and that millions of people
know me but my god
why must did you be such a problematic
guy right but the reality is that you
know you give an inch to to these
intellectual terrorists today tomorrow
it's another inch the next day is
another interact so when we are
discussing things like whether there are
two sexes and that's a viable
conversation we've already gone down the
slippery slope pretty far and so this is
why I fight it but the reality is that's
that's my occupation right is to seek
truth so in the same way that when you
see someone in an alley being mugged you
can be one of two people you could
either pretend that you didn't hear
their screams and go about your way or
you could jump in and try to intervene
well I am the cop of truth or one of
many cops of truth if I pretend that I'm
not hearing all of the killing of truth
all around me then I'm not a very good
cop of truth and how did we get into
this mess because it just seems that
it's beyond parody now like for instance
in comedy like a good friend of ours you
probably know him as well Andrew Doyle
said that at one point talking about men
and women in comedy was the happiest
subject in the world people would roll
their eyes boring now you do it you can
feel the tension in the room where is he
gonna go with this why have we come and
why have we arrived at this absolute
nonsense yes oh by the way Andy doors
been on my show great guy so uh yeah
please do look I think it's a
combination of many things but it goes
back to what I talked about earlier that
in my book I try to identify where the
virus set of viruses or idea pathogens
began at the university it's there
really it's a confluence of several
ideas that each of which tried to remove
reality they want to be unshackled by
reality right so I don't want to have
this thing called male or female tied to
me wouldn't it be better if I could
simply add the prefix trans and suddenly
I could become anything I don't like
the idea of being Lebanese Jew with
olive skin can't I just put transracial
and I could become a black man or an
Asian man because I self-identify I
don't like this thing called scientific
truth can't I develop a field called
post-modernism whereby there is no
objective truth rather all that matters
is my truth so one of the things that I
talk about in the book is that all of
these idea pathogens share an equal
commitment to being unburdened by the
shackles of reality right they do it
using different strains of viruses but
they're all committed to being free
tract for example social constructivism
the idea that we are all born with empty
brains right tabula rasa and we have
equal potentiality is a very freeing
idea right so you mean I could have been
the next Michael Jordan if it weren't
only because mommy didn't hug me enough
you mean there isn't some innate
biological reason why Michael Jordan at
six foot six and a vertical leap of 48
inches might have had a better start to
his trajectory in the NBA well that
feels a lot more freeing to me to know
that my son could be the next Michael
Jordan or the next Lionel Messi or the
next Einstein I don't want to be tied
down by this racist thing called reality
so you take all of these confluence of
idea pathogens that tries to free us
from reality and forty years later you
end up exactly where we are and since
you're using the metaphor of virus God
let me run with it a little bit more and
I ask this question of David Starkey who
we had on our show well it feels like
about three years ago but it was just
before the lockdown came in so for a
virus to be effective in infecting
people yes you need a virus and you talk
passionately and eloquently about how
the virus was created but what you also
need is an organism that is susceptible
and vulnerable to the virus so what is
it about Western society at this point
in time and perhaps over the last couple
of decades that we have been so utterly
open to this infection so so I think
depending on which idea pathogen you're
speaking of
will necessitate a different answer but
let's take for example the cultural
relativism idea who are we to judge the
cutting off of clitoris is of little
girls right it's racist I must admit
it's it's phobic right well that comes
from a a ethos of self-flagellation
right and I actually talked about this
in the in the book that it's in many
religious rituals right what in in for
example in Shia Islam in some Catholic
strains or Catholic sects you had a
tradition of self-flagellation right if
you remember the name of the rose the
famous original ebook but then a movie
with Sean Connery there's a famous scene
where one of the monks is
self-flagellating because through
self-flagellation
I can sort of extricate my sins right
that's a form of piety right well I
think for for for a wide range of
reasons the West has been infected with
with a self-loathing perspective right
all ills come from the West and
therefore anything that you see there is
a way to link it back to evil white man
- white colonialism - white science
right and therefore cultural relativism
then becomes a consequence of that right
the noble ground people can't be doing
something wrong because they are noble
ground people so how could you be
criticizing their religious imperative
to engage in clitoris cutting when
reality is it's the white man that is at
the source of all evil now you might
think that I'm being hyperbolic I'm not
there is a movement called
anthropologists of peace I think I first
heard that term in Steven Pinker's book
the blending slate it was in 2002 where
there is a whole group of
anthropologists who genuinely believe
that war and all of the violence is
really a product a recent product of
sort of Western colonialism because
because we don't have any data Western
it
prior to British colonialism since you
are in England and that men engaged in
any kind of violence they just kind of
had fig leaves in their genitalia they
walked hand in hand and shingles they
sang imagine by John Lennon but it is
really white flag that has introduced
this brutish right you have to return to
the era of the noble savage jean-jacques
Rousseau right noble savage well today
the noble brown people is the
instantiation of the noble savage not
against Savage I don't mean it in a
derogatory 10th sense this is the
jean-jacques rousseau term so he so I
just gave you one analysis of how
cultural relativism is the byproduct of
progressive self-loathing which by the
way is very interesting because and I
talked about this in the book at the
individual level to engage in
self-loathing is a marker of you having
poor mental health right if I go see a
clinical psychologist and I exhibit
endless manifestations of self-loathing
well that's we found something to work
on during the next ten therapy sessions
on the other hand at the cultural level
if I engage in self-loathing
of my culture then I am progressive so
to self-flagellating at the altar of
self-loathing is a progressive virtue so
it's insane
but God have you know heard that Genghis
Khan was woke he was quite progressive
in terms of religious tolerance and a
bunch of other stuff he was pretty
progressive know when it came to the
ladies I might know it wasn't there a
study that showed that I came over with
in which area but something like 1/8 of
people have some descendants of Genghis
Khan and his marauding gang yeah so he
was a very very handsome and popular guy
and he was just a very he was a good
feminist and that's why the ladies loved
him on tender love and by the way I hope
you do know that Islam is a feminist
religion how specifically is it feminist
gun well there are many ways by which is
feminine is the one that I love the most
so speaking about idea pathogens radical
feminism which really spawned in many of
the academic centers
argues now this is again this is not
because I'm also known for being very
satirical and sarcastic I'm not being
sarcastic I'm being literal here the
burqa the niqab and to some extent the
hijab are liberating the bikini is
shackling now why is that because the
bikini is a tool of the patriarchy that
tries to objectify women and and then
you get visually raped by men right the
male gaze on the other hand what better
way to avert the visual rape of women to
stop male gaze than by putting women in
black tents that's very liberating this
is not hyperbolic this is literally what
many feminists Western feminists argue
now they didn't run for their lives in
Lebanon because they were of the wrong
religion so they could sit in their
[ __ ] offices at Wellesley College
and pontificate about this kind of
stupidity but to go back to your earlier
question when you come from the Middle
East and you listen to this stuff you're
like I can't look these people are
insane and you talk again using the
virus metaphor that there are vaccines
against these type of ridiculous ideas
can you explain what these vaccines are
yes thank you for that question so in
Chapter 7 of my forthcoming book I had a
the chapter looks at something that I
call neurological networks of cumulative
evidence so bear with me because I'm
going to go through vastly
overestimating how intelligence either
intelligent e-service is that I promise
you
neurological networks of human the
evidence is basically it's an
epidemiological tool whereby you try to
collect as much evidence from as many
separate lines of evidence that you can
find in order to construct an argument
it's not a literature review so in
science usually when you're doing a
paper you then you start off by
providing a literature review so let's
say you want to see is there a link
between asthma and coffee caffeine
consumption
I'm gonna do a study on that well first
I would like to contextualise my study
in relation to all of the previous
studies that have looked at this Lange
so that's a literature review normal
article networks of cumulative evidence
is a very very different beast the the
original guide that you could think of
who was really the granddaddy of such
thinking would have been Charles Darwin
because although he didn't call it
nomological networks have killed their
evidence so in Charles Darwin in trying
to prove his theory of natural selection
he didn't conduct a single study with 40
undergraduates he didn't run one
observational study instead what he did
assiduously over several decades is he
collected data from an incredibly broad
range of sources from geology from
paleontology from animal husbandry from
and so on so that when you put all of
this evidence together it becomes a
impenetrable wall of evidence it's very
difficult to try to argue against it
because I am drowning you in evidence so
now let's take this idea and give you an
example of that and I'm coming I'm gonna
come to your question of what is the
accumulation it's actually to learn how
to think this way so if I want to prove
to you that the that men have a evolved
preference for the hourglass figure that
the female hourglass figure how would I
go about to try to prove that to you
well I could then start thinking what
would be the distinct lines of evidence
from many many different disciplines
different time periods different
cultures different methodologies all of
which proved my points so let me give
you a few examples so we know for
example that women who have a particular
hourglass figure are likely to be more
healthy more fertile so there is a link
between that particular morphological
feature and the ultimate currency of
evolution which is can you reproduce so
already that is a lot of compelling
evidence then I can go to many different
cultures cultures that are not only
Western I could go to the yanomamö tribe
and the Amazon who have not been exposed
to media images right for those who
might say oh it's media and
that teach you that reference and I
could show that those men have the exact
same breakfast in other words I can
replicate it universally across 50
different cultures I could use brain
imaging studies whereby I could show man
either the hourglass figure or not and I
could show that their pleasure centers
will light up when they see the woman in
the hourglass Hitler I did a study this
is my own study where I did a content
analysis of the advertised hourglass
figures of online female escorts meaning
prostitutes that advertise their
services online so I haven't I had a
research assistant go to 48 different
countries where these women are
advertising their profiles and of course
it turns out that the hourglass figure
by the way the hourglass figure is a
waist-to-hip ratio between point six
eight two point seven two now so as you
can see I'm now offering you medical
data fertility data neural imaging data
contemporary modern online internet data
now here's the kicker and by the way I
didn't give you the full nomological
network you could take congenitally
blind men meaning men who have never had
the gift of sight make them go through a
so elicit from them their preferences
now you might say well how would you do
that you do it haptically by having them
touch mannequins with different ways to
hit ratios and guess which mannequin
they choose at there as a preferred one
that one so what have I done here I have
said to myself what would be the data
that I would need to amass together as I
said from different disciplines
different time periods different called
oh you could take art history dates Oh
data from ancient Greece ancient Egypt
Africa India and do a Content analysis
of their figurines and that's the
hourglass figure you get so I could now
go in front of 400 rabid radical angry
feminists and as I have man I walk in
with all the swagger that I'm known for
and I presented the data and I
not afraid of the pushback and then I
usually will talk and say I can't hear
anybody attacking me what's going on why
the silence why because I've built you a
nomological network that's impenetrable
I didn't get emotional I didn't get
lunatic I didn't get hysterical I simply
put on the epistemological hat that says
what would I need to convince my most
intransigent audience member so the
grand inoculation against these bad
ideas is to start learning how to think
not so much only like a scientist
because most scientists don't know about
the store that I'm talking about is to
think like a well-trained evolutionary
scientist precisely because evolutionary
psychologists are so often the butt of
hostile detractors all of whom
collectively have the IQ of my shoe but
nonetheless those detractors are
viscerally hateful of evolutionary
psychology because they don't like the
idea that the same processes that
defines your dogs
rhaskos behavior can also explain why I
prefer this made versus that mate
humans are somehow above their biology
so precisely because I have been so much
at the receiving end of within my
colleagues of a lot of hostile reactions
I had to learn how to diffuse their
rabid attacks by convincing them calmly
through science so to answer your
question in a very long-winded way but I
think I needed to do this way is you
have to learn how to think like a
dispassionate collector of information
and the the fundamental name for that is
neurological networks of cumulative
evidence if you went all that way just
to show basically that many pigs exactly
what we are but again it is fascinating
talking to you we've got probably about
25 minutes left fear one of the
frustrations for us whenever we talk to
someone like you who's got so many
interesting things that we could talk to
about is that you know like we get you
or Jeffrey Miller or Dinah Fleischmann
on the show and then we spend half an
hour talking about so god please prove
to us that men are actually different
from women and please you
like these very basic things that
everybody actually knows right so I I
mean I I've I'm very interested to read
a book nonetheless but I let's move on
to talking about some of the other work
that you do there in some of the
research that you do I first of all tell
us a little bit just as a with you
clearly have expertise in a number of
fields when you look at the coronavirus
response and people's behaviors and the
government response in Western countries
particularly what do you see from your
mindset and your kind of conceptual
filtered that we've done right that
we've done wrong what stands out for you
so what I I'm not sure if this is gonna
exactly ask you a question but one of
the things that I've done since the
shutdown is I wrote several articles on
my psychology - they call them that are
all in some form or other coronavirus
related and so maybe I could kind of
answer it that way right and so I
thought okay well what you know what are
some things either in my personal life
or in my knowledge base as an
evolutionist that I can write about that
somehow links my personal life or my
evolutionary background to the
coronavirus and so let me give you a few
of these examples so one of the things
well I think maybe the first article
that I wrote of the series was one where
I argued so there's a study by some
fantastic evolutionary behavioral
scientists where they looked at the
distribution of scores on collectivism
and individualism around the world
so China collectivist right Far East
collectivist Arabic countries
collectivist Britain England Canada
individualist right I am individualist
societies is I'm first an individual
then I'm a member of a group
collectivist who cares about the
individual the group is what matters
most
you're just a incidental part of the
larger group right and so what they
showed is that the distribution of
countries in terms of how they score on
individualism or collectivism is
correlated to pathogenic density in
those cultures meaning cultures whose
who have higher pathogenic load in those
cultures are more likely to be
collectivist now you might say what why
what's the link so what they argue is
that collectivist societies are able to
Institute for example rituals that
protect against pathogens more easily
precisely because they're collectivist
norm following becomes easier to do when
you're in a collectivist society you're
more likely to have a clear demarcation
between the in-group and out-group
therefore that also creates a barrier
against pathogenic transfer so then I
took that idea and then I then linked it
to a personal reality so being Jewish I
there was a guy who wrote a book called
I think the paleo manifesto John Durant
where in the book he talks about how
Jews historically have actually fared
quite well in these types of condemned
eggs which basically causes the
anti-semites to argue that demonstrates
that they are the devil because how come
the rest of us are all dying whereas
these bastard Jews are still alive and
faring well well it turns out that of
the metes vote the Miche vote are the
613 commandments not not that 10 major
Commandments but their commandments of
daily life so these are called in Hebrew
meets vote good deeds so of the 613
means both roughly 15 to 20 percent
according to john durant relate to
purification rituals right so there is
this cultural religious mechanism that
has transcended several millennia that
has caused jews to find a way to protect
themselves against a lot of these
pathogenic transfers now i took this
idea and then applied it not to my
culture of religious heritage but
personally I'm someone who free
coronavirus is morbidly terrified I'm a
germophobe right so if we if we travel
and there are two things that I fear
mosquitoes and contamination and I
always joke that I'm actually perfectly
adaptive from an evolutionary
perspective because it makes a lot more
sense to be afraid of mosquitoes than
great white sharks or grizzly
because by far the animal that has
filled most more humans by many orders
of magnitude than the next biggest
animal that has killed us are the
mosquitoes so I see a mosquito in the
house I turn into a little girl but I
can go to New Mexico and hang out in an
end clave with adult wolves and I don't
bat an eye I'm not at all scared but a
mosquito turns me into a little girl
right fear of being contaminated by
things causes me to pre Corona never
touch things I don't touch the handle at
Starbucks when I travel at a hotel my
wife goes through a whole deformation
process to make sure that everything is
clean because if you know what I don't
know if you've ever seen those studies
about what happens in hotel rooms and
the stuff that there is there I mean
it's coronavirus on steroids and so so
one of the things that I've been doing
is trying to write articles that link my
interest in evolutionary theory with
coronavirus but I can't really answer in
terms of the you know what are we doing
right what are we doing wrong because
you know act bring in three rabbis and
you'll get five opinions I think it's
the same thing bring in three
epidemiologists and you'll get 37
opinions and they did the shut down too
early not early enough we should open we
should not I could bring you big experts
in epidemiology that will say the
perfectly opposite thing so I'm not
really sure I can comment on that you
made a comment actually in one of your
articles which are really enjoyed by the
way which and the comment and I wrote it
down and says those who engage in
political mud singing are the tribal
hacks and/or ignorant fools and that
really struck a note with me could you
explain a little bit of why you believe
in that because it's something I believe
very deeply in as well as specifically
relating to the corona because that
article or generally yeah corona but
more generally as well because I think
that's very important for our time since
the please explain that so in the in the
targets of the corona virus I was
basically arguing that the people who I
know a lot of people don't like Trump
derangement syndrome but it'd be truly
is that I actually use a different
mechanism I call it a form of collective
Munchausen so I don't do you know what
Munchausen is yes
it's yeah it's yeah so the munchausen
syndrome it's where you believe that URL
and therefore you go into hospital you
believe you're ill you faith that you're
ill so that you can garner sympathy and
empathy right okay right that's that's
that's munchausen syndrome what hasn't
syndrome by proxy is where you take
someone who is under your care usually
your biological child but it could be
your elderly parent it could be your pet
and then you harm them so that you can
garner the sympathy and empathy or look
poor Suzanne she has a ill kid so her
site psychiatrically deluded need of
getting that empathy and sympathy causes
her to harm her own biological child so
in 2010 I had written a paper in a
medical journal where I was trying to
explain which houses syndrome by proxy
from an evolutionary perspective and
then that germ of an idea then turned
into what many people now known before
as related to Munchausen where I talk
about my theory of collective Munchausen
T I'm a victim therefore I am ethos
right so the idea is that it is
wonderful to link everything to some bad
villain and therefore I'm a victim so
Trump is the bad villain so in that
article where you quoted that quote of
mine I was talking about to politicize
the coronavirus so that if I hate Trump
anything he does is a manifestation of
how evil he is if he shuts down the
border if he's racist if he doesn't shut
down the border it's because he doesn't
care about American lives right I mean
there's I can I can construct any state
of the world as a manifestation of how
diabolical here's and what I was arguing
is that try to rise above that and see
that our common enemy today is the
corona virus it's not trumpets Obama
wouldn't have done it differently or any
measurably different way so but now more
generally to answer your question more
generally for that quote I always say
belong to the tribe of truth in other
words so when people ask me so what are
you are you Liberty are you Republican
or even though I'm Canadian so
Republican and Democrat don't lie to me
and I say I'm neither of these things
I'm a man of each idea on its own merits
so when it comes to the death penalty
I'm actually for it so
that would make me a Republican well at
case when it comes to socially liberal
issues that would make me a Democrat
because I don't give a damn who you
sleep with in your bed or whether you're
transgender or not so I would be Supra
liberal there when it comes to
immigration I would be considered Supra
right-wing right so you can't pin me to
any pigeonhole label because I have this
thing called a brain that allows me to
think on each issue based on its merit I
don't care about belonging to the IDW or
the group of Canadians or the group I am
gat sad with my merits and flaws and as
Luther said here I stand right I stand
on the merits of my arguments so to go
back to the quote that you you quoted so
kindly forget about political tribalism
follow the truth in some cases
Republicans say super stupid things call
them out on it in some cases they say
the right thing but the problem is that
I in eighth psychology regrettably is
tribal right one of the features the art
the architecture of the human mind
is that it views the world as us versus
them there's Blue Team and Red Team I
mean literally in this case red is right
and there's a great study and I I don't
remember the reference and I've for many
years tried to find out because I had
heard it in a class when I was a
graduate student you bring in people
into the lab and you put them into a
waiting area and you give them you
literally put like a red dot on them or
a blue dot and you say oh I'm gonna come
back in a few minutes to administer some
tests but ostensibly what you're doing
is you want to see their behavior once
you've given them this random cue and
what happens the red people start
banding together and the blue people
start banging together so at this point
it doesn't matter if I'm gay or straight
you or not tall or short fat or thin
it's this irrelevant queue has become
the way by which I assort the world for
that micro moment right and so this is
what ends up happening in our political
discourse I am a Democrat there for Joe
Biden could not have done something
wrong even though I see him molest
little girls on camera for the past 40
years he can be because he's a noble
Democrat breath Kavanagh is an evil
Republican therefore even though the
woman who came out after him christine
Blasi Blasi ford
36 years after the fact she can't
remember where when how what nobody can
corroborate but he must be guilty now
this is not some idiots who are
succumbing to this type of thinking some
of the my clothes or maybe not clothes
some of my some of the people who run in
the same intellectual circles as me who
are very famous who you would know
exactly sir come to this idiocy why
because they're not driven by the same
personal conduct as me and again I'm not
trying to sound you know haughty but as
I said what I go to bed at night and I
put my head on the pillow what drives me
is that I do everything that I can to
try to protect truth to the best of my
ability
if yes I sleep well at night if not then
I'm a fraud so I am only belonging to
the tribe of truth whatever that truth
might be at that moment political
tribalism is not that political
tribalism is I belong to a group first
damn the truth there you go god I just
had a piece actually about that very
thing and published think roulette
talking about the the Cavanaugh the the
Biden all of that do you think I mean
one of the things that strikes me is
that it's inescapably obvious now that
some of the the traps that are being set
by one side for the other and now
turning out to be traps that anyone can
be trapped by you know this thing of for
example believe all women right once you
introduce that you are absolutely [ __ ]
because at some point someone in your
side is going to come along and it's
gonna turn out that they've been doing
things wrong it's just the way of the
world right so do you think maybe some
people are gonna start to wake up now
and go some of this stuff that we've
been doing in the last few years or is
it just my naive optimism talking no no
I think listen if your optimism weren't
something that we can all aspire to have
in the future then there's no point for
me to get out of bed right because he
said I navigate in the ecosystem
that is most infested by this [ __ ]
right academia is the corner virus of
the human mind Center right this is
where the [ __ ] is right
by the way this is one of the reasons
why when people say to me well how come
you don't criticize Republicans more or
the right more and as I explained in my
book an ox and I've explained a million
times before let me explain again that's
me that's like asking a dermatologist
but brah what about diabetes right okay
if I'm a dermatologist I deal with skin
related issues that doesn't mean that
diabetes is not important but I'm not an
endocrinologist
I am a dermatologist in my daily life I
operate in an ecosystem that is
completely dominated by the left right
most of the idea pathogens that I speak
of in the book are completely the
product of insane leftist progressive
stupidity right
therefore I attack that not because that
is my secret attempt to communicate to
the world that I am a right-wing guy but
that's because those are the diseases of
the human mind that I'm exposed to right
so as a parasitologist of the human mind
I deal with parasites of the left now if
a Republican senator comes out and says
evolution is a hoax and we should be
teaching intelligent design then I will
also go after him but the reality of my
daily life is I am attacking leftist
ideas because that's what I see all day
but so to answer your question I do
believe that we can win the idea I do
believe that people can turn around but
I think it's a generational fight right
you have to have all of the original
spreaders right just like a corona virus
can spread the spreaders of the [ __ ]
are the professors who for the post
passed 30 or 40 years have been spewing
this nonsense to their students once you
have enough people come and attack these
ideas or once these guys die out or
retire then we will start seeing changes
but this is why by the way I tell people
you don't have to be a famous professor
with a huge fall
and so on to to effect change if you see
in your classroom your professor spewing
something that you are you disagree with
challenge them politely if you see
someone post something on Facebook or if
you're at a bar and somebody says
something idiotic challenge them the
problem is that most people are cowardly
so what they do is they subcontract this
fight to a few public people but you
know what my shoulders are only so big
right now it just so happens that I have
the type of personhood that I'm very
combative I mean I'm very nice and very
warm and very sweet but you come after
me I come after you ten times harder
right that's why sometimes people say oh
but on Twitter
why are you sometimes mean well when
you've insulted me for the past six
hundred days then I say okay let me
bring out middle eastern boy let me rule
to be relentless in going after you and
usually they shut down their accounts by
the way once I decide that I'm coming
after you it is endless how much I come
after you right so people have to and as
a term that I've used before grow a pair
you have to have testicular fortitude to
say I have a say in this pattern of
ideas I should also contribute it
shouldn't be just God side and Joe Blow
and John Smith who fight on our behalf
we and by the way this is one of the
things I talked about in the last
chapter of my book called the chapters
called call to action don't diffuse the
responsibility onto others trigger your
honeybadger
your inner honeybadger if you don't know
the honey badger is a astonishingly
ferocious animal it's my favorite animal
god thank you so much I'm a memory
budget but I've never seen him this
excited for weeks cat I love them
they're incredible sorry carry on can
help my honey badger is you know the
size of a small dog you can just go on
google if you're watching this whenever
you're watching it and see a honey
badger face down six lions and the night
lions look and say what and they're like
this is too much right so when people
see me 99.9%
time I'm extremely mellow I'm extremely
sweet I'm a very affable guy but if you
attack me in an alley I am not sweet and
affable then I will fight and that's
different than when I am tucking my
children to bed this is called the
fundamental attribution error right you
attribute things dispositional II when
you should be attributing things to the
situation right so on Twitter I use that
medium to usually smackdown someone not
so much because I'm smacking they might
have only 12 followers but because I can
use that opportunity for the audience to
watch how you never back down from a
bunch of lions if you're a honey badger
and so to go back to your original
question Constantine yeah I do I am
optimistic but big caveat if the silent
majority chooses to rise up and then
fight for the Battle of ideas if it
remains on four or five 10 people to do
so we will lose the bomb and you say
that but isn't evolutionarily a reason
for people not to get involved in this
fight in that they're terrified of being
ostracized by their group
like for instance myself and Constantine
there are look we're in the world of
comedy I think it's safe to say a lot of
comedians don't like us now I don't mind
that because I like because I like
pissing people off yeah and I have that
Arabic left in America were you gonna
[ __ ] with me well you know we let's go
then
but I think most people want a quiet
life don't they and they want to be part
of the in-group so yeah so look what
happens is that any given point there
are multiple Darwinian poles putting me
pulling me in different directions right
I have made a monogamous commitment to
my wife so and now that's triggering my
innate moral compass that doesn't mean
that I may not have temptations to
straight so I could go on straight or I
could stay monogamous that those are
pulling me in different directions
I haven't evolved preference my
gustatory preference to eat a lot of
fatty foods but then I receive my
cholesterol score that pulls me in a
different direction I know
oh so to answer your question yes there
is a part of me that's fully
towards wanting to lead a quiet life but
to those who take the great risks come
the great rewards right Emperor's who go
to war then have a harem of eight
hundred gorgeous girls the little
schmuck who's plowing his field can't
get one wife hit through history right
so I'm the Emperor who is willing to
take all of the great risks so that that
now again I don't mean to imply that I
think those risks because I want the
adulation or so on but what I'm saying
basically is now you want 800 undergoes
lead to propose to one just one by the
way I should mention that I have a study
published in the journal behavioral
medicine that looks at so remember what
I mentioned that in my doctoral
dissertation I look at how much
information do we need to look at before
we commit to a choice let me just put
this into gallery so everyone can see
Francis faces go forget it so I applied
that framework so I got older sedation
was in 1994 and this is a paper that I
published in 2009 if memory serves me
right so many years later I applied that
framework specifically to make choice
the idea being I applied that what's
called a sequential stopping model so
sequential in that you acquire
information and then you decide have I
do I have enough information to make a
choice if yes I stopped if no I acquire
more information and so I applied this
model specifically to make choice and
let me just give you the quick kind of
punchline when it comes to rejecting
prospective suitors in other words how
much information do you need to look at
before you decide that a pair of suitors
are losers women reject suitors much
more quickly right in other words they
need less information to decide that
they are disassociating from those
perspective suited when it comes to
choosing a final mate then women acquire
more information before they make that
final choice now the fact that in
rejection mode they acquire less
information but that they it when they
choose mode they acquire more
information is actually perfectly
explained by
evolutionary theory called parental
investment theory the guy who proposed
it as Robert rivers who was still alive
some have said arguably that the biggest
evolution biologist says Darwin that's
saying a lot
he's come up with some unbelievable
theories that I've been influential over
the past 40 years parental investment
theory basically says that across
species right and now here please don't
be triggered it's assumed that there is
such a thing as male and female in each
of those species sexually reproducing
species I incredibly transform it but if
if you want to know sex differences
within a species you need to look at the
minimal parental obligatory investment
that each sex provides within that
species for most species males only
provide a copula torie act and that they
leave right all of the minimal
obligatory parental investment is
carried by the females therefore because
of that they have to be more judicious
in their mate choice they have to be
more careful because the cost of making
a suboptimal mate choice loom much
larger for females now by the way there
are species that are called sexual
reversal species where if the exact
opposite it is the mayors who are
smaller the males have less testosterone
the females build harems of males yeah
in England we call that area Islington
that's what a super liberal progressed
well done you got the joke I call them
sneaky [ __ ] syndrome yeah anyways so
so in those species you have the exact
opposite pattern of sex differences so
imagine how unbelievably powerful that
theory is it can in one swoop explain
the pattern of sex differences across
two million sexually reproducing species
without a falsifiable data point right
so to the incredible imbeciles who argue
that evolutionary theory is nothing but
just so storytelling unfalsifiable
nonsense
they couldn't be further from the truth
because the reality is evolutionary
theory is unbelievably falsifiable
episome illogically the fact that you
can't falsify a book falsify it speaks
to its veracity to it being vertical
it's not because episome illogically you
can't falsify it it's because it's true
right if a hundred people jump off a
building and a hundred of them crash
it's not because gravity bra is
unfalsifiable is because gravity exists
and it's recurringly
the same pattern that will happen so
that's one of the things by the way that
that caused me to develop this normal
logical networks of cumulative evidence
you know chapter seven right because I
have to fight against this idea that so
you basically sit around professor and
just come up with [ __ ] post hoc
explanations and but you couch it as
evolutionary psychology but isn't
evolutionary psychology pseudoscience
nothing could be further from the truth
before an evolutionary psychologist can
claim that something is an evolutionary
trait he sets the threshold speaking of
threshold he sets the cumulative
threshold incredibly higher than all the
other sciences
so it's the so that which we are
attacked is actually the opposite of
what the truth is and that's why I find
it so galling and by the way it's
usually fellow academics who levy that
accusation which upsets me that much
more if it were just a Twitter [ __ ]
then it's fine he's sitting in a space
basement playing gamer stuff but if it's
a fellow academic who says oh it's too
bad doctor sad that you know you wasted
your career on you know a pseudoscience
like evolutionary psychology well why
should you say stuff like that then my
I'm gonna roll up the sleeves and I'm
coming after you god you've got to be
careful with the insults my friend
because for last five weeks we've all
been sitting in our basements playing so
have you gotta be careful in this brave
new world there was but listen it's been
absolute pleasure chatting with you I
wish we had more time and once all this
stuff is over either when you're in
London or we're in Canada we'd love to
talk to you face-to-face because I feel
like there's so much other stuff we
could discuss but now that we've got to
let you go before we do that we've got
one more question for you
and that's the way we finish every
interview which is what is the one thing
we're not talking about it's a society
that we really should be facetious
answer or realize it because I haven't
prepared a real answer so let's do it
whatever you want go for it
facetious answer there's a lot of
pressure on him now isn't it
why is it why are we not talking about
why Ariana Grande has more followers
than the 100 top I guess that's not a
fast answer more than the 100 other via
top reigns in the world in other words
what why is it and I'm thinking about
this from a parasitic perspective right
more people are willing to listen to
listen to the quantification of ariana
grande or Billie Eilish because of the
platform that they have then if I stood
on my platform and screamed all day and
I wish there was a way for us to talk
about how we can devalue and I guess
some people are doing with that how we
can devalue the social capital worth of
celebrities and other naturally
lobotomized fools and maybe we can have
the philosophers and the intellectuals
and the academics being the celebrities
of our world not because I am one but
because of someone who pursues truth I
I'd like more kids to have as their
heroes intellectual Giants rather than
people who die rate and twerk and sing
yeah but as we know from an evolutionary
point if you got that doesn't get you
laid
I'm fighting an evolutionary dead end
exactly exactly listen thank you so much
for coming on I cannot wait to read your
book is coming out in October exactly
and it's called the parasitic mind how
infectious ideas are killing common
sense we're gonna look forward very much
to reading and we look forward to
speaking to you again make sure you go
and follow GAD on Twitter and all the
other social media and we'll see you
very soon with a live stream or another
interview thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all
Media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word